Coffee is normal,
MP3 can be washed, do it, let's
cross it due to dry tomorrow evening,
then let's go till four news,
this is
our Ghaghra, we employ so many people
to
do it again
[Music] Do it, it's done
Whatever has happened to us, this is the area of ​​our purpose, we should
cover that there are other people too,
you have to listen to us in this area, like
in one career there is one in another, there is a
third in this, this is how we go for each other.  Let's
go,
where is my phone? When the situation was bad, we used to
wake up through the phone. It was a
habit of us to live in the city to the maximum. Till Shahrukh Khan did
not come, we did not think that it
was Ramzan, so we have been watching this edition since childhood.
Shahrukh Khan is there and we also enjoy his arrival a lot.